- I LOVE PATTI LABELLE.
I LOVE--SHOUT OUT
TO PATTI LABELLE, HONEY!
I WENT AND BOUGHT
THE PATTI LABELLE PIE.
SWEET POTATO PATTI LABELLE.
THIS IS THE PATTI EDITION,
HONEY.
THIS IS THE...
♪ ON MY OWN ♪
BUYING THIS PIE--
IT'S HARD TO GET IN THIS
MOTHER[BLEEP].
PATTI, WHAT YOU SEAL
THIS BITCH WITH?
GORILLA GLUE?
OOH, IT'S SO PRETTY.
LOOK AT THAT.
MMM.
♪ ON MY OWN ♪
♪ WHY DID IT END THIS WAY? ♪
COME ON, PATTI.
SO LET'S TASTE THE PATTI.
I WANT TO TASTE PATTI.
OOH, PATTI'S SO MOIST!
COME ON, PATTI!
PATTI!
- I'M ALWAYS HESITANT
TO TELL A BLACK PERSON
THEY REMIND ME
OF ANOTHER BLACK PERSON,
BUT HE REALLY SOUNDS
A LOT LIKE PATRICE O'NEAL.
THAT'S JAMES, AND SINCE
HE POSTED HIS FABULOUS REVIEW,
WALMARTS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
HAVE BEEN COMPLETELY SOLD OUT
OF PATTI LABELLE'S
SWEET POTATO PIE.
I HAVE A HARD TIME BELIEVING
ANYTHING FROM WAL-MART
IS EDIBLE,
LET ALONE DELICIOUS.
- HERE WE GO.
PATTI...
IF ANYBODY KNOW PATTI LABELLE,
TAG HER IN THE VIDEO!
PATTI!
♪ WHOA, YEAH! ♪
BITCH, I'VE TURNED INTO PATTI.
YOU'LL TURN INTO PATTI
AFTER EATING THIS.
[SINGING INDISTINCTLY]
I SWEAR.
♪ PIE ♪
- PIE?
THE GREATEST PASTRY CHEF
IN THE WORLD
COULD MAKE HIS BEST PIE,
AND IT WOULD NOT BE AS GOOD
AS THE WORST BROWNIE.
AND DON'T GET ME STARTED
ON PUMPKIN PIE.
JACK-O'-LANTERN GUTS
AREN'T FOOD,
AND THEY'RE CERTAINLY NOT
A DESSERT.
IF PUMPKIN PIE WERE ANY GOOD,
IT'D BE AVAILABLE YEAR-ROUND.
YOU KNOW
WHAT YOU'VE NEVER HEARD?
"UH, OUR SEASONAL MILKSHAKE
IS CHOCOLATE."
BUT VIRAL SENSATIONS LIKE JAMES
ONLY COME AROUND
ONCE EVERY WEEK OR SO.
AND SINCE EVERYTHING HE EATS
GETS WILDLY POPULAR,
I FIGURED, WHY NOT INVITE HIM
OVER FOR A TASTE OF TOSH?
EVERYONE, THIS IS JAMES.
- HEY, EVERYBODY.
HOW YOU DOING?
- I HEARD PATTI LABELLE
CALLED YOU.
SHOUT OUT
TO PATTI LABELLE, HONEY.
WHAT'D SHE SAY?
- SHE WAS JUST THANKING ME
FOR DOING THE VIDEO,
AND SHE WAS JUST HONORED.
- SHE NEEDS TO JUST OPEN UP
THE CHECKBOOK FOR YOU.
YOU CAN'T GET THE PIE
ANYWHERE IN THE COUNTRY
BECAUSE OF YOUR VIDEO.
- RIGHT.
THAT 'CAUSE I'M
JAMES WRIGHT CHANEL.
- DO YOU KNOW WHAT ELSE
YOU CAN'T GET IN AMERICA?
- WHAT'S THAT?
- SURSTROMMING.
- PASTRAMI?
- NO, NOT PASTRAMI.
IT'S SURSTROMMING.
IT'S SWEDISH
FOR SOUR HERRING.
- MM-MM.
- I'M TOLD IT'S THE MOST
PUTRID-SMELLING FOOD
IN THE WORLD.
- [STAMMERING]
[CAN HISSES]
I'M NOT USED TO THIS.
- I DON'T LIKE THAT.
- OH, MY...
WHAT THE HELL IS THIS?
- I KNOW.
I'VE GIVEN YOU ALL THE
INFORMATION THAT I KNOW.
OH!
- OH, MY GOD.
- [LAUGHING]
OH, GOD!
IT'S SO...
- ♪ AND THE ROCKETS'
RED GLARE ♪
OH, MY GOD.
♪ THE BOMBS
BURSTING IN AIR ♪
OH, [BLEEP]!
♪ GAVE PROOF THROUGH THE NIGHT ♪
OH, MY--HELL, NO!
♪ O SAY, DOES THAT ♪
♪ STAR-SPANGLED ♪
OH, MY GOD.
- [GAGGING, LAUGHING]
- WHY THE HELL
DOES IT SMELL SO BAD?
- I CAN'T HANDLE IT.
- I OPENED IT.
YOU TASTE IT.
- I'M GONNA PUKE.
- YOU KNOW WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE?
IT LOOKS LIKE POTTED MEAT.
- [COUGHING]
- YOU WANT TO TRY THIS, ANDREW?
- OH, [BLEEP].
- OH, NO. OH, NO!
OH, NO!
DON'T SMELL IT!
- WHAT'D YOU SMELL IT FOR?
[WOMAN SCREAMS]
- OH, MY GOD.
- OH! OH!
OH! OH! OH!
AHH!
- SWALLOW IT!
[ALL SHOUTING, LAUGHING]
[WOMAN SHRIEKING]
- NOW, I'M SURE PEOPLE AT HOME
DON'T BELIEVE
SURSTROMMING COULD POSSIBLY
SMELL THAT BAD,
BUT I ASSURE YOU IT WAS WORSE.
THAT'S WHY I HAVE ONE MORE CAN
THAT I'D LIKE TO POP OPEN
IN FRONT OF MY STUDIO AUDIENCE.
[AUDIENCE GROANS]
[LAUGHTER]
- OH, MY GOD.
- TAKE A GOOD WHIFF.
YOU GET ONE BIG WHIFF.
CAN YOU SMELL IT EVERYWHERE?
- YEAH.
- GARY, COME HERE.
COME HERE.
GARY, DON'T BE A PUSSY.
JUST ONE BIG WHIFF.
THERE. IS THAT BAD?
NO, YOU CAN'T PLUG YOUR NOSE!
- WHAT AM I DOING?
- I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU CAN DO IT.
[AUDIENCE GROANS]
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
OH, THAT'S HEAVENLY.
[AUDIENCE GROANS]
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK WITH MORE
OF THE ROSS DRESS FOR LESS
THANKSGIVING DAY MARCH.